[Music]
wait you thought I was going left no
sorry man I was going I was staying
right I don't know what you saw
but I saw your test with this MFO what
are you [ __ ] kidding me
teamfight tactics is the new kid on the
block who also happens to be the biggest
7.5 k damage the one that came out last
and is doing to auto battlers what
fortnight did to Battle Royale
the one that could transform auto chess
into a bonafide eSport I am so excited I
played this mode way too much and I
can't wait to finally get to cast I
think is the first official cast ever
this is the story of a game that showed
up late to the party and stole the
spotlight wait I lose and you guys
thought I was gonna leave that the story
of twitches latest obsession of [ __ ]
meltem Guerin do carrots [ __ ] this
unit Smurfs did the story of teamfight
tactics
[Music]
several weeks after league of legends
a--'s newest game mode teamfight tactics
was launched on the game's public beta
environment it's become one of the
biggest games on Twitch but this isn't
news streamers have been feeding this
thing since the day it came out from the
biggest names in League of Legends
hey emote it for me alright he's gonna
win I got a great feeling about this I
have to me melees to see CG authorities
I'm gonna tie and I'm gonna lose Oh No
TF T has quickly solidified itself as
the hottest Auto chess variant on the
market it's also the first game riots
released since league of legends
launched back in 2009 look they're not
gonna say it but I will they're
essentially announcing a new game that
game is team fight tactics and if you
are very familiar or if you've heard of
auto chess it is basically riots take on
Auto chest the biggest thing that TF t
had going for it was that it's well
leaked riots flagship IP continues to
boast an estimated hundred million
players and an auto chest variant that
utilizes leagues established lore items
champions and spells was always going to
be a recipe for success TF T is our take
on the emerging auto battler sub-genre
with some new aspects we think make for
a uniquely League experience the thing
that is surprising is that of all the
Auto battlers on the market riots brand
new game is being hailed as the best of
the bunch
not many people expected the makers of
League a game whose entire purpose was
to make dota more accessible League of
Legends is attempting to be the answer
to those needs of the communities
looking for essentially you know looking
to solve the pain points of dota and to
appeal to a much wider audience to
produce the deepest most streamlined and
competitive version of auto chess and
there's so much to think about it's
actually really fun ok the games good
I've decided the game is good but it's
also the one that came out last and had
zero affiliation with Auto chesses
original developer
in order to understand teamfight tactics
we need to ignore it and go back to
January 2019 we're a ragtag group of
Chinese and Taiwanese modders who
operated under the name of dorado studio
uploaded a game mode called dota Auto
chess to steam the point of the game was
simple use currency to buy and draft a
carefully selected group of heroes and
watch as they Duke it out across a
series of chess boards in a battle
royale esque free-for-all nice and [ __ ]
one more nice nice
[Music]
it was turn-based had zero player input
and actually boasted a considerable
amount of detail and strategic death you
get to choose units when the preparation
phase and then they fade out against the
other players creations during the
fighting phase it's spread like wildfire
and it didn't take long for Auto chess
to go viral it was fun easy to
understand surprisingly deep and offered
quick spectator friendly games that lent
themselves extremely well to streaming
[Music]
players could utilize chat to help them
theory craft watch as the selected
heroes went at it and since there was no
input required once the combat commenced
were able to experience the action
alongside their viewers the game was a
streamers dream by March auto chess had
become a full-blown sensation amassing
over 6 million subscribers it boasted
its own wiki subreddit and category on
Twitch there were even reports that
certain Chinese companies were trying to
trademark the term Auto chess the most
notable of which was Tencent the
multi-billion dollar conglomerate that
owns Riot Games to everyone's surprise
dro toe turned down partnership offers
from both valve and Tencent dro toe
wanted to be the ones to bring the newly
popular game genre that they designed to
the world the problem was that everyone
else did too
so while dro were off rushing a
standalone mobile release to market
valve announced that they'd received
dourados blessing to put out their own
officially licensed dota Auto chess they
called it dota under Lord
[Music]
and then out of nowhere
riot stepped in and announced that
they'd be releasing their own league
skinned version of what they refer to as
an auto battle we have been playing an
instant amount of dough that just in
particular so yeah this is very heavily
like inspired by dr. Jesse this there's
a lot of similarities but there's also a
bunch of new things it isn't definitely
not just a clone or something now in the
case of valve Drogo had given them
express permission to copy their game
and riot on the other hand had simply
done with Auto chests what epic games
the makers of fortnight had done with
battle royale yeah I mean I think people
will make comparisons til the cows come
home you know I never say there's that
there's better that's just different I
prefer what I prefer it helped the TFT
was accessible through League of Legends
existing client instead of having to
download and install a standalone game
like dota under Lords TFT was accessible
in a client that nearly 100 million
people opened every month if you had so
much as an itch to see what all the hype
was about TFT was only a click away
on the surface it looked as if riot had
done with Auto chess what they done with
DOTA allstars as if they found a way to
capitalize on the success of yet another
original and ingenious mod guess the
irony here is hilarious the fact that
riots first game league of legends was a
take on dota and now there again I won't
call it a game but their second game is
a take on a dota 2 custom map but ride
added a variety of features and
mechanics that made for a cleaner more
compelling Auto battler experience in
addition to boasting better social
features the game implemented more
synergies and took the champion
selection process to the next level
it's basically a phase where there's a
lot of random units in the middle and
everybody scrambles to pick their
favorite run out of the middle and they
all come of their own separate items
it's pretty fun it reminds me of like a
Mario Party game it soon became clear
that even those who loved the original
Auto chests or had little to no interest
in League of Legends loved all of the
novelties that Riots iteration had to
offer for me like having all the new new
unit bonuses felt so fresh because I
know that once the game launches like
everyone is gonna be in the exploration
phase again what are we trying to figure
out what units are really good and what
what what synergies are good and all
that stuff is like super cool but the
biggest thing TFT has going for it is
it's competitive infrastructure in
addition to finally providing auto chess
enthusiasts with a real ladder to climb
you know dota Auto chest right now
does not really support rent because
they make your own lobbies and stuff if
if right does TFT ranked mode and it has
like actual ranking system and the
ladder that'd be awesome it's a
subsidiary of League the second most
played video game in the world and
arguably the biggest eSport in existence
riots already announced a $125,000
tournament and people have already
started to throw themselves into the
game's burgeoning competitive scene
that's why this group
one is so stacked yeah because it has
hapu and dog and test and yeah and so
those those are like top hundred level
players for normal q MMR SCARA and
reckful are like top 300 which is where
I'm at like 2003 50 mm ah chances are
the TFT will end up being the thing that
truly brings Auto chest in the masses at
the same time Tencent are also behind a
mobile version of Auto chests called
chess rush which allows them to compete
with other on-the-go Auto battlers
whilst TFT continues its growth on
traditional platforms so how is team
fight tactics slated to fare in the war
of the Auto battlers very well but it's
not without its controversy TFT marks
the second time in riots history that
they've managed to profit off of a
pre-existing mod and roto is already
struggling to keep up it's also no
secret that riot aren't the most popular
game studio right now I have only played
under loads and auto chess
I would never support Riot Games so [ __ ]
that game but in spite of all the drama
surrounding riots and the manner in
which TFT came to be the game is likely
to blow both under Lords and the
original Auto chests out of the water
and honestly there's no reason why it
shouldn't people love it and riots
giving it the support that a blossoming
eSport needs in order to grow
it remains to be seen just how far auto
battlers will go and whether or not
they'll have a future in eSports but one
thing's for sure whether it's a fad or
one of gaming's next great generic
evolutions Auto chess has gone
mainstream and it's thanks in large part
to teamfight tactics
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages